Before this video begins I just want to thank you guys so much for 66 million subscribers...
It really means a lot for me, that you guys are still subscribing and showing your suport.
BUT IT'S NOT ENOUGH *felix gets angry*
T-Series is still winning
ARGGHHHHH (ノಠ益ಠ)ノ彡┻━┻
*explosion*
SMASH SUBSCRIBE (ง ͠° ͟ل͜ ͡°)ง
Alright, desperate times
calls for desperate measurements.
If we beat T-series I will bring back bonus meme (YAY)
That's right. *slaps the wall*
Can't let the indians beat us.
Did I just lose 3 subscribers?
:(
What the heck? It's going backwards
"War has..." *deep man's voice*
*LWIAY intro*
Hello, everybody. Welcome back to another week of LWIAY.
LWIAYahHHh
"But Felix, what does LWIAY stand for?"
It stands for shutufhuckuUu
No, I'm just kidding, it stands for: "Last Week I Asked You".
It's an original concept, that I came up with myself. [ORIGINAL CONTENT ALERT]
Baslically, I asked you guys to do something
and the next week I review it.
And the memes just took over the whole reddit
Cause that's what everyoneurugughh (what?) - just uploaded anyway.
But I thought eaeahehehhhhh
Let's make "LWAIY" LWAIY again.
OK? (okay)
So I have a new challenge for you guys:
[high pitched voice] YAIY new challenge!!11! :D
[normal...er... pewds voice again] Yeah, I can see you, I can see you.
So last week I asked you guys to design my "aim-controller.com custom controller"
which will be the official Pewdiepie controller.
This is just not any custom controller, alright? ƪ(˘⌣˘)┐
You got: LIFETIME WARRANTY!
So when you have those epic rage gamer moments, wE GOT YOU cOVERED!
Actually, I don't know if it covers that at all I just felt like that would be a nice thi-*laughs pitifully*
It got smart triggers, alright? (wow)
You'll to be the fastest one (i'm shook :O)
There's a shortened pressure point in these babies, so you'll have faster reaction time then...
your enemies. You'll be the most epic
gamer of all time basically with this controller.
*pewds showing the controller* "Ergonomic Back Paddles" that's right, so you can hold this babie
FOR HOURS
without hurting your fingers.
It also has a mistakes: we should [inaudible] change the hike, the top, all that, good stuff and...different colors.
*claps* NOW LET'S LOOK AT THE WINNER
The official Pewdiepie controller goes to CreeperNinja! This one one by far...22.5k up buds. DAMN, a very nice 👌 *laughs*
with this controller you'll have zero depth
guarantee, baby. I love it, it's so cool <3
and you took the classic PewDiePie meme
and you made it almost better >:D
Congratulations, CreeperNinja. I want to
give you the very first copy of it signed
and I won't sign any other, so
hopefully there's some exclusivity that idk.
Thanks to everyone for submitting,
I'll go through some more later as well *little pewds pops out*: check out the link in description
to get your exclusive aim controller down there, baby.
Alright, let's get into the memes. What
have you guys posted?
"I made him chuckle, the cycle continues"
*thinking*
*laughs*
gOd dAmMiT, are you kidding me? This is the dumbest thing I have ever seen in my life.
There's nothing to pride here. How many times
it has been? One, two...*laughing* NO. *explosion* (?)
"Unboxing the $399 chair" wait, some -  you got the chair? Legend.
"Look what I found..." (T-Series name)
No...
that can't be right.
that cannot be right...T-series is working
with my chair. (oH mY gOd)
*deep man's voice* "War has changed..."
"He secretly owns T-series,
it's obvious" *stares ironically*
who do you think is gonna win this
battle if you see this I hope you like
it
alright that is cool actually that's
very nice
I love that WakDonalds
outfit as well that's super do I'll be
wearing this for my final battle against
t-series I have been training
oh that's epic okay alright that's that
big alright so if everyone does this
then we don't have to worry about it
mad line wipe sixty million people off
the earth found this on Twitter she
wants peers to know this let him see it
can someone please help me tweet
PewDiePie and tell him that he's in my
Mass Communication text books for
calling this is so weird
this is the second time someone told me
about me being in like an actual school
book someone else said what I mean like
a sociology study or something Felix Kjellberg is the most famous person on the
planet you've never heard of what at
least if you're older than 40 and don't
have young people in the house okay
unless you're nine years old this you
could have just said that
don't let him forget
deja vu music cover Oh me myself
get that for our wedding that's
beautiful stop holding me accountable
for my promises and it's a pretty tune I
feel like I could get away with it dude
what if hold it hold on for a second
what if I bought t-series and deleted it
this is so epic spent 25 years making
this incredible I'm so proud to have
fans that really take the time and
dedication to show their support
25 years sex that's a lot of nine years
let me guess
your bike it was but I thought okay damn
it I missed the bike meme that was the
frick and remember that that was the
first meme review the thing that started
it all the bike cook can we appreciate
that this was posted on our anniversary
one year one year without dropping me on
board thank you guys yeah look inspector
it's nothing more celebrating please
stop when you made into intellectual
video by living in a simulation but you
your subscribers want you to play Lego
Star Wars does anyone actually want me
to play Lego Star Wars if this video
gets 500 million thousand likes is that
too many if this video gets 400,000
likes I will play Lego Star Wars okay
it's a main design so it has chances to
win the comfort
I mean yeah that's pretty clever
actually that's really good their rule
is simple you lay you loose just do it
Wow thank you Nike for the millions of
millions of dollars that I was paid for
my giant sacrifice imagine if I stopped
doing YouTube and then this company paid
me millions and millions and everyone be
like what a sacrifice what a hero
review the mean even if it means
sacrificing see why don't I where's my
Nike deal you know control the
submission plus merch plus channel Cour
damn taking the extra mile by sinister
Bulgaria these are very cool actually
the shirt is though I like it I do
really like making it myself although I
do appreciate you guys submissions of
like banners and stuff like that
I do like designing those kind of stuff
myself it makes it more personal all
right how long do you guys think that
Thanos car mean will be popular please
place your bets in the comments right
now the winner will win Lego playthrough
I'll invite you bros to my wedding how
about that stop stop holding how many
prophecies have I made okay first up if
we beat t-series I will invite you okay
how's that
smash subscribe
wow that's so nice to see another
nine-year-old played the theme that I
composed my very self thank you very
much the most trusted me that's sick I
like that actually my entry for the
controller company that's sake I like
that actually
okay so for next week of Lawai I'm gonna
leave a download link for a bunch of
photos since you guys like relatable
pictures where you can go that's me
I'm gonna do you guys a favor of adding
a bunch of reaction faces that you can
put in your favorite meme everybody the
best ones will of ready to review next
week Lavoie thank you guys so much for
watching and all the support honestly
I'm so lucky to have you guys
my favorite 9 gurus thanks for watching
this video guys and thanks Jenny
patrollers for sponsoring it it's a very
cool product I think you guys are gonna
like it
link in the description bye
also indian 9 year olds are welcome to join the army